[Musique]
monsieur comment séduisent et vous
comme sa
cible à 8 heures j'arrive geagea proche
d'elle j'ai eu dire alors heureuse
je barre est une peau oui c'est vrai la
plupart des filles qui sortent avec lui
c'est pour sa crainte c'est comme un coq
dans une basse-cour quoi bouger elles
sortent avec lui parce que bon bah elle
aime bien se faire remarquer avec un mal
qui change de l'ordinaire quoi je suis
une sorcière et donc j'utilise l'art du
rituel c'est à dire le verbe les plantes
les nuits de pleine lune et puis
quelques fois une petite goutte de sang
pour faire bon poids bonne mesure
[Musique]
c'est que je me fous un peu de la gueule
du garçon en début je peux me casser la
gueule carrément mais si lui à la
répartie c'est extrêmement agréable et
épuisant à cette soirée vraiment on a la
tête complètement morte mais c'est très
agréable au point de vue séduction
j'essaye de m'allumer en fait elle
succombe tous mes désirs elle s'abaisse
devant moi elle se traîne par terre dans
la boue dans la fange dans les détritus
ce
alors que moi je séduis vraiment j'en
sais rien ve je veux dire quand j'étais
adolescent je ne pensais pas je parlais
devant la cheminée où je marchais sur
les dunes sans oser aborder les filles
très romantique les très solitaire 13h10
et
je ne regrette pas et je crois que
jamais une femme miral dans votre lit
qu'elle ne l'est profondément souhaité
j'attends cela stratégie d'araignée je
vais dans un lieu un café je rêve puis
peu à peu elle se rapproche d'un jour à
l'autre elle est dans une banque est
plus pop et puis laisse tomber un objet
et on se parle on part ensemble moi
j'aime les hommes sexy sexy et les
sommes qu'on a envie de toucher tout de
suite
ça m'arrive très souvent cherché bien
que ça se fait pas mais ça m'arrive très
souvent d'avoir omis envie de mettre la
main aux fesses des hommes sauf que les
fesses c'est important c'est rond c'est
bon on a envie de caresser passer la
main dans les cheveux aussi très souvent
et je dire qu'il faut il faut faire
gaffe parce qu'on peut pas faire ça
n'importe quel mec ça marche pas
toujours donc il faut choisir son
partenaire chez kaze 1 et
[Musique]
donc j'ai juste qu'il me faut à la
maison
et j'ai plein de choses à faire très
occupé donc j'ai j'ai pu le temps ça
m'intéresse plus j'ai pas gène hilton il
envie de séduire je cherche pas à
séduire donc je regarde pas non plus si
je séduis ou pas en plus quand j'ai pas
mes lunettes voir ya donc si ça se
trouve c'est du personnes ou puis je
sais rien je préfère vraiment pas partie
de mes préoccupations par contre la
sécurité sociale alors là oui ça ça
m'emmerde je crois que dans notre
société aujourd'hui il y as abus de
séduction il y a abus de
2,2 de domination par le paraître est
trop souvent notre société des médias à
laquelle chacun d'entre nous participe
et je me replonge moi même parfois 10 cd
ou d'y participer cette société finit
par dissimuler la réalité vous vous
trouvez séduisante
mais de plus en plus je pense
est très prétentieux je me trouve de
plus en plus prétentieuses mais refusant
depuis que je suis président c'est
suffisant vu que je me trouve séduisante
bac général ou trouvez-vous séduisant
on va écouter le sait comme le vieux
caïman aux yeux pochés quoi à 67 ans
peut pas être séduisant c'est sûr je ne
sais pas si je suis séduisante enfin je
fais le maximum pour ça j'essaye de
réunir le maximum d'atouts pour avoir un
aspect agréable quand j'entreprends la
danse de la séduction c'était vraiment
je m'en fous c'est pas l'homme qui est
en face de moi que j'ai envie de séduire
mais c'est le miroir c'est moi même mais
quand je suis moi-même séduite et qui
j'ai envie de séduire là c'est beaucoup
plus compliqué et la plupart du temps je
perds tous mes moyens
bernard tapie quel est votre image de
marque mauvaise
mauvaise moi je suis passé du coeur
super mon métier je me présente pas aux
élections et je fais pas de cinéma par
contre je suis séduisant par les
résultats que j'amène et votre argent ça
peut séduire beaucoup plus que mon
charme beaucoup plus sage fait pas long
de l'anneau dont vous vous trouvez
séduisant
ouvriers ça n'est pas séduisant non non
c'était
notre être flic c'est un handicap pour
séduire absolument pas répond je ne
pense pas je crois même que l'uniforme
ont encore un petit peu de prestige à
l'heure actuelle auprès de qui mais
auprès des dames bien sûr auprès des
dames mais oui je dois dire que les
dames de de 40 ans et au delà sont
particulièrement sensibles aux à
l'uniforme les jeunes est moins bien sûr
mais les dames et séduire vous habillé
en femme pourquoi
parce que je me trouve beaucoup mieux
habillé en femme camp shira hommes
je suis je me sens insignifiant je me
sens petit
je suis très mal dans ma peau quand je
suis en dame alors qu enfin pour moi
c'est autre chose ça me permet de
m'épanouir
de me plaire à moi-même d'abord d'être
bien d'être bien dans ma peau pourquoi
vous séduisez
parce que c'est indispensable
j'ai pas envie de rester tout seul toute
ma vie puis j'ai envie de mai mais j'ai
envie de le sentir puis si je suis pas
populaire parce que moi disons je fais
je travaille pour être comédienne pour
être mieux si ça fonctionne pas du tout
au point de vue carrière j'ai envie que
ça fonctionne dans ma vie que je plaide
du que choix si je suis pas une actrice
dans le monde et que j'en sois une en
avis quel personnage principal j'espère
dit nous quelque chose que vous dites
aux femmes pour leur plaire bonjour
ça suffit oui
[Musique]